justin trudeau veut montrer qu'il ne
perd pas de temps il reçoit le maire de
la capitale canadienne du pétrole son
grand plaisir d'accueillir le maire
d'annecy et de cadbury si ottawa le
premier ministre répète que le sort de
l'ouest lui tient à coeur mais surtout
aussi un avenir meilleur et plus
prospères pour tous les canadiens
incluant les adaptations l'aliénation de
l'ouest et les craintes des albertains
sont bien réelles insiste le maire de
calgary naheed nenshi demande des
actions concrètes comme des
modifications aux lois ses 69 et ses 48
qui renforce les protections
environnementales mais sont perçues
comme un frère à l'économie albertaine
on doit parler tous les ouvertures
nous sommes ouverts à revoir la loi
affirme le nouveau représentant de
justin trudeau dans les prairies une
déclaration qui a semblé surprendre des
ministres québécois à l'entrée de la
première rencontre du cabinet d'années -
[ __ ] je n'ai pas vu c'est comme un
terme à mes mais je reviendrai là dessus
la question actrices comme on peut bien
faire la france et énergétique
le nouveau ministre de l'environnement a
cru bon de rectifier le tir
il n'est pas question de modifier les
lois controversées mais peut-être rendre
plus flexible leur mise en oeuvre
nous sommes ouverts de conversation avec
l'industrie avec les
environnementalistes
ou comment on peut implémenter la loi
dans une manière efficace
l'opposition s'inquiète du signal envoyé
est craint un recul
il y avait déjà beaucoup d'arbitraire
avec ses 69
si on l'affaiblît davantage on va
retourner au règne des conservateurs de
harper au delà de l'ecoute ce sont des
gestes concrets qui sont attendus dans
les prairies pour aider les industries
pétrolières et gazières
le premier ministre doit tendre la main
sans compromettre ses principes
environnementaux les divisions qui se
sont cristallisées lors de l'élection
rendre sa tâche encore plus délicate
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa